ever wonder why certain celebs homes
look so magical well it's because many
of them know celebrity designer brad
schmidt
[Music]
are there any celebrity trends you think
that will happen this year
i think people are going to go over the
top adding more trees to more rooms
adding garlands they're bringing family
in and they want it to be
happy and they want to celebrate again
need more celeb worthy decorating tips
we teamed up with brad in balsam hill to
help you create an effortless and
beautiful holiday look give me a few
tricks and tips so my house can look
amazing one of the things is selecting
the right tree for your house so if you
have a small area and a wide living room
you might want to get a shorter more fat
tree when you have tall ceilings i
always go for the more slim like nine or
ten foot slims balsam hill christmas
trees are beautifully realistic and
their decor is handcrafted with care
what are some other tips and tricks
picks and ribbon to your trees then also
extra ornaments you can put them in the
center of your table on coffee tables
all over throughout the house
where can i get all the things i need
for this holiday season you can find
everything at balsamhill.com